out of stock out of stock out of stock
out of stock Behind These numbers a slow
Panic is setting in over strep a
community demand for antibiotics has
shot up and with it prices eight pound
for antibiotic we're looking at 10 pound
for an antibiotic
you know that is not normally the case
on Friday another child died at a
secondary school after Contracting strep
a while at this Oxford Pharmacy there
are empty shelves in my 10 years I've
never seen amoxicillin being you know
out of stock or call Maxi clavada stock
or penicillin V4 treating you know let's
say strep throat strappe and being out
of stock has never happened 10 years
what you're saying today is that you
could you could buy amoxicillin for you
know let's say 90 Pence but now you
can't get it for more than three or four
pound and it's out of stock that's not
happened in 10 years that I've been
qualified that's a serious problem
Laura has three children the eldest has
strep a she's had to call around
multiple pharmacies to try to find
antibiotics it's supposed to worrying
really it just panic because you you
rely on these services to be able you
know to be able to get antibiotics for
your children and they're not there
what what do you do you know they tell
you not to go to a e because you know
you'd be treated out in in the community
but what you're forced to do to go there
thank you see you then bye a raw
material issue to make antibiotics
overseas and supply chain covered
complications have made things difficult
alongside that Sky News has spoken to
pharmaceutical industry leaders who say
that the minute there's a shortage like
this look these shelves in the middle
are normally packed full of antibiotics
then stockholders will take advantage of
this charging whatever they like some of
them making hay while the sun shines
profiting from the enormous demand
because of strep a
government say it's normal for prices to
fluctuate based on demand what's
important is patients are still able to
access antibiotics which they are but
some pharmacies are struggling to cover
costs a lot of pharmacies are finding it
very difficult to actually pay the
wholesalers Bill and so it's if if this
continues and the Department of Health
and the government doesn't do anything
about it then we are going to be seeing
a lot of our pharmacies shutting the
doors for good over the coming months
when do you think you're going to be
able to get some back in no idea no idea
the government's working to help
expedite deliveries but as the number of
children falling ill Rises and more are
turned away a sense of unease is growing
Adele Robinson Sky News